ah il ya quelques jours je vous parlais
du nouveau rock phone 5 qui est le
nouveau smartphone de gaming d'asus je
posais donne boxing jeu découvrez en
direct avec vous devant les caméras et
aujourd'hui il est temps de vous dire ce
que j'en pense vous dès mon retour
complet sur ce smartphone alors là il ya
encore un petit peu chaud parce que j'ai
pas mal joué avec et ce smartphone il
est je vous dis tout de suite il est
vraiment super bien
asus maîtrise vraiment bien toute la
partie gaming sur ses smartphones et sur
le roc 25
c'est vraiment une petite tuerie avec
plein de mode super cool
il ya un mot rick wright vous vous y
retrouvez tous vos genoux et pouvoir
paramétrer pas mal de choses que ce soit
dans le jeu que ce soit avant le jeu
paramétrer bien évidemment la
performance me dire ce que vous voulez
exactement il ya plein de réglages qui
sont vraiment super aussi au niveau de
la batterie puis surtout ce qui va choix
intéressant ici c'est l'écosystème est
4ème avec tous les accessoires
accessoires de manette vous pouvez venir
enlever vous pouvez non venir mettre ici
votre smartphone à l'intérieur utilisez
vos deux petites commandes soit pour les
mettre directement sur vos smartphones
soit venir les intégrer ici ça vous fait
une petite manette en fait qu'elle avait
vraiment une prise en main ergonomique
est super cool soit carrément le mettre
là dedans et là pour le coup êtes
vraiment dans l'idée de la valette
harper je vais vous montrer je vais vous
le détailler je vais vous expliquer
comment ça marche je vais vous expliquer
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec et on va
donc regarder une expérience gaming sans
accessoire et puis on va regarder avec
accessoires parce qu'un plein
d'accessoires il ya effectivement déjà
ne serait-ce que cette petite base là
c'est le aéro active couleurs qui vous
servira à venir refroidir votre
smartphone france quand son équipe a les
plus légers néanmoins il est là il est
performant et moi je trouve super bien
[Musique]
pour moi la première chose à voir ici
c'est effectivement l'écran parce que
l'écran il est assez dingue worth un
écran samsung ici c'est un écran amoled
écran été conçu spécialement par samsung
pour ajuster une commande d'asus en fait
au niveau de ce smartphone là vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 144 r ce
qui va vous apporter encore plus de
fluidité lorsque vous allez venir jouer
regardez par exemple vous allez si dans
armorique wright vous allez dans le mode
x et dans le mode xp dire modifier
modifie pas mal de choses et notamment
modifier votre taux de rafraîchissement
soit le plus et en 144 tout le temps
soit dans 120 soit en 60 pourquoi pas le
laisser en automatique comme ça il va
s'ouvrir automatiquement en fonction des
applications avec elle vous est un
smartphone de gaming c'est pas juste de
la performance c'est pas juste un dragon
888 c'est pas juste une techno drame a
été la bière 5 ce n'est pas juste du
stockage en nuage est trois points en ce
qu'il fait en tout cas tout l'intérêt
tout l'attrait d'un smartphone de gaming
c'est toutes les options vous allez
pouvoir voir derrière tout ce que vous
allez pouvoir venir paramétrer au niveau
de l'expérience globale ou naveau
l'expérience logiciel pourrait venir
notamment paramétrer une sensibilité de
glissements précision de glissements
sensibilité tactile
parce que si vous avez un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 3 100 hertz
l'une à tence de 24,3 millisecondes et
lorsque vous slide est de 18
millisecondes prat extrêmement précis
ressasser des données qui viennent de
asus j'ai pas de la boétie pour venir
mesurer ce genre de choses mais en tout
cas ce qui est sûr est que je retiendrai
ce que je vois c'est que c'est
extrêmement fluide pour venir jouer un
jeu déjà au niveau de l'écran géant
super affichage en delta ultérieure un
géant des croquis vraiment très très
bien calibrée complètement optimisé pour
l'unità gaming ça c'est clair point qui
est intéressant de vous retrouver à
l'avant un corning gorilla glass vite tu
cette dernière génération de verre
corning gorilla glass par contre à
l'arrière un examen du corps ni dans la
glace 3 j'imagine que c'est pour des
questions de coûts en plus si vous avez
un écran de 6 78 pouces et plus grand
que ce conte avec le rock fauntroy
l'année dernière le truc qui est
intéressant est le parti pris c'est là
où on voit que dans un smartphone de
gaming et je vous l'avais vraiment dit
déjà leur donne donc si votre caméra les
planqués ici ce qui fait que vous n'avez
pas du tout d'intrusion avec une petite
caméra un petit poisson nulle part dans
l'écran absolument pas toute la zone
utilise une zone de jeu donc ça c'est
plutôt bien aussi
ça vient rapporté en immersion parce que
lorsque vous jouez un jeu quels qu'ils
soient un peu j à call of duty ou un
asphalte et compagnie eh bien vous
n'êtes pas pollué par ce qui va se
passer sur l'écran vous n'avez pas de
zone de pertes en tout cas
d'informations alors très très
légèrement comme votre écran est
légèrement arrondi sur le côté vous
perdez quelques petites informations
mais voilà c'est
vraiment du pain de détails voyez là sur
mon niveau de batterie je crois que ça
doit être ici se voit pas mais ça vient
pas non plus poser un problème dans
l'expérience globale moyens tout surpris
vachement interpellé lorsque j'ai
commencé à ouvrir ce smartphone eut
commencé à jouer avec
c'est la qualité audio et la qualité
audio est absolument incroyable et ce
café a jusque là dessus qui est
vachement bien c'est que vous avez un
double parleurs en façade haut parleurs
sur la droite un parleur sur l'album
j'avais la même directivité du son vous
avez la même puissance d'un côté lot
avait le même spectre smartphones qui
était classé numéro 1 en audio du côté
de chez xo mac jusqu'à il ya très peu de
temps qui a été surclassé par un autre
smartphone n'est pas vraiment
globalement pas grand chose est ce que
j'apprécie vraiment cette clarté le son
vous voyez vraiment vous en êtes vous
entendez d'où viennent les tirs
notamment ici sur un punch et ça c'est
vraiment mais vraiment vraiment hyper
hyper appréciable justin totti beaussier
dxomark tu peux me rappeler ce que tu
pêches et ici c'est ça non moi je suis
je m'occupe de toute la partie recherche
développement pour les produits audio
chatrix en marquant leur rock 5 c'est
vraiment une évolution sur toute la
partie une restitution sont donc en les
des vidéos quand on joue de la musique
quand on joue à des jeux
c'est une évolution par rapport à notre
précédent top score qui était le 1010
pro ok mais là où il ya vraiment une
grosse avancée ce sera à partir
d'enregistrements sert quand on va pour
vouloir enregistrer que ce soit une
vidéo en selle fille ou une vidéo où on
va enregistrer quelque chose qui passe
devant nous ou même enregistré des mémos
c'est vraiment là où peu importe le cas
d'utilisation va voir vraiment un rendu
qui va être très naturel très bien
enregistrer on a un volume qui est tout
le temps conséquent une balance onale
qui est très propre et vraiment c'est
vraiment un téléphone qu'on va pouvoir
embarquer dans toutes les situations et
d'avoir à chaque fois un résultat qui
est intéressant c'est pour faire du
gaming moi j'ai envie de parler avec les
bâtiments ligne pour aller faire mes
jeux l'ag ils vont me capter je vois
rançon qui va être vraiment bien sans
aucun problème alors il devrait capter
rebondir c'est un téléphone qui est
équipé de quatre micros en plus
ouais donc il ya peu de chances qu'on
les blocs avec les mains et les argos
ont vraiment bien fait pour que ça
compense et qu'on puisse avoir vraiment
à son bon dans la majorité des
situations ce qu'on pourrait reprocher
c'est peut-être que si on monte un peu
trop le volume on a envie d'un léger
manque de basses en un volume qui est
vraiment bien au niveau mondial de
jusqu'aux deux tiers de la barre de
volume et après ça devient un petit peu
centré vers les médiums mais dans
l'instant c'est vraiment très fort
l'année dernière déjà elle avait fait le
choix de passer sur dira qu'au niveau de
l'audio et le choix est vraiment très
mais bon ça marche super bien et pour
moi ce qui m'intéresse vraiment une fois
de plus ses côtés spatialisation c'est
le côté qualité de son lorsque vous êtes
dans un jeu pour savoir bout est ce que
ça tire alors il ya un autre point qui
est super intéressante et je vais sortir
de là avant que ça commence à canards et
tous les côtés c'est le retour de la
prise jack
le retour de la prise jack il est venu
grâce à une question de composants en
fait puisque l'année dernière vous
n'aviez pas à la place en tout cas est
ce dû ces dernières n'avaient pas la
place de venir conserver sa prise jack
devait faire des choix et grâce en tout
cas je pense au sein dragon 888 édiles
ont pu remettre cette petite prise jack
parce que la différence que vous avez
ont trouvé sa dragonne 888 et le 865
qu'on avait l'année dernière est bien
c'est que sur le 1 888 vous avez votre
modèle 5 g qui est intégré directement à
votre puce
ce qui va permettre de libérer de la
place dans smartphones et notamment de
retrouver de la place pour cette prise
jack et donc ça c'est vachement bien et
ça nous permet justement de venir
connecter votre casque et notamment ce
petit accessoire là est très sympa c'est
le rock setra deux corps vous avez votre
caste casque micro pour venir jouer pour
me dire parler à votre équipe à votre
team en direct en restant dans l'univers
rogge
donc ça c'est très très cool vous la
retrouvez également aussi sont
l'aéronautique couleurs vous voyez que
vous venez insérer directement en
dessous
hop là on fait le point juste ici ils
ont été plus longs également au niveau
de la partie audio vous avez quatre
modes différents j'allais pouvoir venir
customiser un dynamique
musique cinéma je modifie un petit peu
votre école leaders syndicaux l'isr a
band je vous parle de gaming parce que
c'est un smartphone de gaming on
transpose tout ça dans l'univers de la
musique si vous voulez par exemple
écouter de la musique écouter un morceau
quel que soit votre plate forme et bien
vous allez pouvoir les plus longs
également grâce à votre équaliseur ça va
être la même chose pour la lettre des
films des séries
et puis la troisième partie le troisième
point très important également sur un
smartphone de gaming va c'est la
performance puisque derrière ici vous
avez un scindera gones 888 qui est le
dernier soc de qualcomm qui en tout cas
aujourd'hui le plus performant avec l'a5
j'ai intégré je voulais dit vous pouvez
aller jusqu'à 16 go de ram c'est la npd
d'hier 5 et jusqu'à 512 go de stockage
en effet trois points en géant le score
qui est assez énorme seront en tout 2
730 1188 ce qu'il a voulu classer en top
score en plus haut est ce que je fais à
730 milles le plus aux 6 et 7 125 milles
sur le classement dans tout ça veut dire
façon qu'il ait pas répertorié encore
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est renversante
y est pas très longtemps mais il est
devant tout le monde autant vous dire
qu'il écrase littéralement la
concurrence et qu'une fois de plus avait
une vraie bête de performance pour tous
les gamers pour toutes les personnes qui
veulent vraiment
la performance ici vous avez vraiment ce
qu'il faut que ça c'est extrêmement
important la performance c'est bien mais
si derrière vous n'avez pas une bonne
autonomie ça ne sert pas à grand chose
alors ici vous avez deux batteries de
3000 milliampères heures ce qui vous
fait un total de 6000 millions terreur
pour votre smartphone autant vous dire
que c'est quand même relativement énorme
deux batteries qui vous permettront de
venir recharger les deux batteries
individuellement en fait c'est pour
avoir de la faible tension il
rechargeait beaucoup plus rapidement
mais surtout parce qu'il a bien
intéresser ici c'est toutes les options
que vous avez au niveau du rechargement
parce qu'il ya un très gros boulot a été
fait par asus notamment le fait d'avoir
une charge constante je viens recharger
un rythme lent pour protéger la batterie
bien qu'ici vous ayez un chargeur de 65
watts contre 30 watts pour rock band 3
il est plutôt recommandé de venir
recharger lentement sans smartphone pour
prolonger la durée de vie des batteries
qui fait vous allez les branches et le
soir il va se recharger tranquillement
tout doucement mais plus sereinement
pour votre batterie pour avoir aussi une
recharge planifié dire que par exemple
entre 22h et 7h du matin et bien vous le
voyez là vous allez venir
il a rechargé pouvez sélectionner aussi
une limite au niveau de la charge d vous
voulez chercher jusqu'à 80%
ça sert à rien le charger jusqu'à 100%
80% c'est bien une fois de plus ça veut
dire prolonger la durée de vie de la
batterie de votre smartphone est
globalement ici vous rechargez votre
marque de 0 à 100% en 52 minutes et 2 0
à 70% seulement 30 minutes vous avez
compris qu'en fait les 30% restants
c'est là vous allez être plus lentement
mais avez-vous réellement besoin de
recharger jusqu'à 100%
une fois de plus je vous dis non mieux
vaut aller jusqu'à 80% ça suffirait
largement il le fait d'avoir une double
batterie ça sera beaucoup mieux d'un
point de vue thermique votre smartphone
chauffera - et vous aurez une meilleure
dissipation thermique
vous avez également différents modes au
niveau de l'utilisation de
l'alimentation de votre batterie
ici le mode x qui seront les meilleures
performances pour les jeux ça veut dire
consommer davantage ici j'ai un mode
dynamique c'est à peu près à peu près
équilibrés ultra durable ensuite ça me
permet d'économiser un peu la batterie
poyart sam le messie du tram du ratage
vaut donc quoi je suis et je peux aller
aussi également dans l'avant c'est comme
ça je peux aller beaucoup plus loin et
voyez ici a par exemple c'est tout mais
paramètres limitation thermique
performances du processeur performances
du gpu un carte graphique performance de
la ram je peux forcer les restrictions
d'alimentation du processeur en
arrière-plan février je peux vraiment
aller très très loin j'ai également
notre mode c'est super intéressant qui
va venir prendre à l'énergie directement
dans mon chargeur et pas dans ma
batterie en brosse un bypass de ma
batterie c'est à dire que je le branche
sur mon secteur soit par la soie par en
dessous lorsque je suis en train de
jouer d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup mieux
on sait par en dessous parce que c'est
plus ergonomique en fait vous le thonier
dans votre main comme ça et toute
l'énergie va rentrer directement like
c'est à dire que l'énergie rendent
directement et discriminante ou
smartphone mais ne passe pas par la
batterie et ne se stocke pas dans la
batterie ce qui veut dire que lorsque
vous jouez pendant des heures en étant
branché sur le secteur
votre batterie n'est pas du tout mise à
contribution et ne va pas s'user donc ça
c'est très bien pour profiter des
meilleures performances
et pour prolonger la durée vie de votre
batterie si vous jouez beaucoup sur vos
smartphones tous les jours et vous avez
la possibilité d'être branché sur
secteur
ça c'est vraiment génial alors il ya un
autre point qui est super intéressant
sur ce smartphone scellé hier trigger
les airs trigger qui sont arrivés
l'année dernière je crois si vous
connaissez ils sont situés en fait j ce
travail sont vraiment planquer et super
bien intégré ses marques et ici rogue
wave dernière rigueur gauche ont reçu un
bouton vous allez avoir en plus ici et
vous avez l'autre ers trigger de l'autre
côté ils sont un peu plus espacés par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière ce qui fait que c'est plus
facile pour venir jouer et voyez on
trouve plus facilement la position on
vient - entre autres du smartphone on
est vraiment sur le côté on client plus
avec ce smartphone vous avez toutes les
dernières technologies notamment du wifi
6e
la seule partie un petit peu moins
intéressante et si c'est la partie photo
vous allez avoir parce qu'ici on est sur
un smartphone de gaming on n'est pas sur
un smartphone pour venir faire des
photos alors on peut venir faire des
photos je peux pas dire qu'on n'est pas
là pour bien faire des photos on peut
vous avez trois caméras narnia mais
c'est pas ici vous allez avoir le
meilleur rendu au niveau de votre
appareil photo c'est pas là vous aurez
la meilleure expérience il a bien fallu
que je fasse des choix également parce
que c'est un smartphone qui coûte quand
même aussi relativement cher à fabriquer
regardez là vous êtes sans grand-angle
c'est complètement cramé au niveau du
ciel c'est assez imprécis le point je ne
sais pas où il est fait c'est vraiment
pas extraordinaire on passe sur l'ultra
grand angle c'est un poil mieux mais
rien de bien dingue
non plus ici c'est assez imprécis en
fait on en voit partout la gestion des
lumières est pas très bonnes les
couleurs sont pas d'un go bon vous
pouvez faire des photos pour y faire des
souvenirs mais c'est pas le smartphone
fait pour ça on le voit faut vraiment
oser des conditions optimales mais même
là dès lors la partie luminosité pas
d'âme ça devient lisse et c'est assez
imprécis d' un peu partout on vient
ensuite chercher un petit peu de
maquereaux je suis pas fan de maquereau
en mai sur un capteur de 5 mégapixels le
rendu est pas dingue dingue hausse est
difficile de trouver la bonne distance
pour avoir un point et la caméra de
celle fille est pas non plus voilà bon
vous l'avez compris si c'est pas un
smartphone qui l'est pour faire de la
photo mais ce qui fait la richesse de ce
smartphone c'est vraiment cet écosystème
et le fait d'avoir tous ces produits
mais tout premier qui vachement
intéressant c'est la héros actifs
couleurs qui vous permet de lire
dissiper la température de votre
smartphone lorsque vous venez jouer avec
que vous avez derrière c'est que vous
avez un ventilateur qui va venir
régulier à température de votre
smartphone grâce est vachement bien sa
vie à dissiper davantage la chaleur et
puis à vue c'est un petit peu plus loin
cette année on vous rajoute ont de
petits boutons alors ça va dépendre des
jeux auxquels vous jouez prévenir les
maps et moi celui qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est celui-là c'est le coup nay 3
gamepad parce qu'il a fort vraiment de
la modularité
vous pouvez venir mettre votre
smartphone dedans garde et hop vous
assez réussie dans la prise usb c'est
comme ça il vient se poser il trouve
très très très très bien sa place et
ensuite vous venez mettre les petits
contrôleur tout le côté et ça vous
transforme en une petite console et je
trouve ça juste vraiment tellement bien
pensé et au niveau de l'expérience on
sait pas tout nouveau et les accessoires
un peu comme ça sur le rock funk d'asus
comme ça vous avez une vraie console il
vous suffit juste de venir paramétrer de
venir faire le mappy lorsque vous êtes
dans un jeu c'est génial donc à cette
expérience là comme ça et si vous
souhaitez vous premier votre smartphone
vous le posez ailleurs vous prenez ça
comme ça la regarde et hop vous venez le
mettre dans les glissières et ça vous
permet de jouer directement comme ça
avec votre smartphone posé en face vous
avez une vraie que vous pouvez dire
bougez vous énervez l'écran ne bouge pas
en quoi c'est super si vous voulez
vraiment l'expérience ergonomique vous
posés çà et là vous avez eu cette petite
tenue au niveau de la main c'est super
et là vous retrouver en plus d'arrière
et vous le voyez les boutons qui sont
juste là vous avez deux boutons ici vous
avez quatre boutons sur le haut vous
avez votre ipad
vous avez enfin voilà vous avez tout ce
qu'il faut il suffit de venir l'allumé
vous démarrez vous connecter marche ou
ça vraiment vraiment bien
gros bénéfices du fait d'avoir ça et
l'utilisé surtout ton smartphone comme
ça c'est ce que je préfère mais en tout
cas vous n'avez pas avoir les doigts sur
l'écran vous êtes vous une zone qui
complètement dégagée au niveau de
l'écran vous voyez tout ce qui se passe
dans votre écran au niveau logiciel
c'est aussi très complet vous a
notamment dans l'affichage vous avez
toute une gestion de la lumière avec
votre voyant des autres voyants led en
fait que vous retrouvez sur le haut qui
vous permettra de savoir si vous êtes en
train de recharger ou est-ce que vous en
êtes vous avez une notification donc ça
c'est plutôt bien fait voyez faudrait
vraiment passé beaucoup de temps à vous
montrer tellement il ya de choses ici
puis surtout ce fameux mode là qui reste
vraiment je dirais le gros point fort
vous allez retrouver ici le mode
armorique waits avec votre mode console
mais pour venir régler même au niveau
des paramètres voyez la vitesse du
ventilateur qu'on peut venir paramétrer
le génie du jeu les airs trigger pas
personnellement j'aime bien je trouve
très intéressant ce smartphone alors
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous de
ce rock 25
c'est pour moi un super smartphone si ce
n'est aujourd'hui la meilleure
expérience de gaming sur smartphone ou 3
mois celle que je préfère la plus
complète
on va vraiment très très loin asus est
extrêmement fort là dessus sur son rock
phone 5 donc si vous voulez un super
smartphone de guémy qui fera absolument
aucune concession rock 25 les tarifs je
les avais quelque part laissez moi juste
voulais redire c'est un smartphone qui
coûte en configuration 8 plus 128 go de
stockage 799 euros 12 250 6 899 et 16
250 6 999 et après ce coup monté jusqu'à
512 go de stockage il ya un mode pro un
smartphone process 512 c'est déjà
beaucoup 1199 aprilia mode ultimate là
c'est un truc de dingue au 18 juillet de
ram 512 ziga de stockage 1999 euros
et puis vous avez pas d'accessoires
genou mais les liens en bas dans la
description pour moi une fois de plus su
vraiment conquis c'est un smartphone qui
est très bien équilibré qui n'est pas
excellent en photo mais c'est parce
qu'on a cherché ici qu'il est un peu
lourd cercle si vous mettez en mode x
l'autonomie elle va baisser énormément
vous allez tenir même pas une journée si
vous devez beaucoup en mode x par contre
si vous choisissez votre plus équilibrée
vous pourrez tenir un jour un jour et
demi ça va dépendre soit plus de vous de
votre consommation du temps que vous
allez passer dessus mais ce résultat si
vous avez la charge 65 watts à basse
tension derrière permettra de le
recharger rapidement
tous ces modes intelligent sur la
recharge donc on peut complètement venir
leurs charges et de la nuit très
facilement sans venir altérer sa
batterie enfin l'expérience elle est
super elle est complète le smartphone il
est très beau j'aime beaucoup
bravo asus et si vous voulez insu
smartphone de gaming vous pouvez aller
sur le roc fun 5 sans aucun problème les
yeux fermés voilà vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous trouvez sur roc 25 il ya
deux couleurs moi j'aime blanc comme ça
que j'aime beaucoup
il ya également une autre colonne voit
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler de teck parler
également d'asus tort quelques temps car
le tour complet tout ça va là ça je vous
embrasse moi des gros bisous beaucoup
d'amour des coeurs pour les soins de
ville ya bientôt